The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
All right.
We are in the middle of acids
and bases.
And we are just going to finish
up the handout from Monday,
starting first.
And we were talking about
relative strengths of acids.
If you have an equation such as
this, there is acid-base
chemistry going on in both
directions.
In the forward direction,
HNO three is acting as
the acid.
It is giving up its hydrogen
ion or proton to NH three.
And when it gives it up,
it is forming its conjugate,
NH three minus.
And when NH three
accepts a hydrogen atom or
proton, it is forming its
conjugate acid,
NH four plus.
That is what is happening in
the forward direction of this
reaction.
In the reverse direction of
this reaction,
NH four plus is
acting as the acid.
It is giving up a proton to NH
three minus.
When it gives up the proton,
it is forming NH three,
the conjugate.
And when this accepts the
hydrogen ion or proton,
it is forming its conjugate
acid.
In this direction this is the
And in the reverse direction
this is the acid.
You can predict something about
where the equilibrium lies,
whether it is to the right or
the left.
If you have a big K or a small
K for this reaction based on
whether this is the stronger
acid or this is the stronger
acid.
If this is the stronger acid
the equilibrium will lie to the
right.
If this is a stronger acid the
equilibrium will lie to the
left.
And so we can take a look at
this and work out which is the
stronger acid and where the
equilibrium lies.
Here is the equilibrium
constant for this reaction.
Again, it would be products
over reactants.
And so to find this number,
we can work through it by
getting information about the
the Ka or acid ionization
constant for this acid and for
this acid.
We can consider the reactions
separately.
We can consider this acting as
an acid and also this one.
Let's start here and consider
the forward direction of the
reaction and consider how good
an acid HNO three is.
You all should be able to write
reactions of acid in water or
bases in water and figure out
what the products are going to
be of that.
If we have NH three in
water then we are going to be
forming hydronium ion and the
conjugate base of this conjugate
acid here.
And then we can write a Ka.
And it is a Ka because we are
talking about an acid in water.
The Ka is going to be equal to
the products over the reactants.
And here water is not included
because it is the solvent and
its concentration really isn't
changing through the course of
this reaction.
And we can look up an
equilibrium constant for this
acid, and that is 20.
Is that a strong acid or a weak
acid?
How did we define strong acid
last time?
It was a Ka if it is greater
than one.
20 is greater than one,
so this is a strong acid.
Now we can do the same thing
for the reverse direction.
In the reverse direction,
the acid is NH four plus.
We can write NH four plus
in water.
And that would go to hydronium
ions.
And the conjugate of this acid,
which is NH three.
We can write out a Ka
expression for this.
Again, it would be products
over reactants.
And here the Ka,
which could be looked up,
is 5.6x10^-10.
Is that a strong or weak acid?
That is a weak acid,
so the Ka is quite a bit less
than one.
Already we can predict that for
this overall reaction it will
lie to the right.
This is a much stronger acid
than this one.
We can prove that that is true
by using these two Ka values to
get the overall equilibrium
constant for this reaction here.
If we took those two individual
reactions that we wrote out and
subtract them,
we can get our overall
expression for the reaction.
And if we subtract them then we
can come up with the K by
dividing the Ka's from each
other.
Remember we talked about Ks,
if you add together you
multiply, if you subtract
reactions you can divide?
And so we could prove that this
is true, that if we have the Ka
up here and the Ka down here,
it will cancel to form the
equilibrium expression for the
overall reaction.
And we can substitute our Ka's
in, 20 over 5.6x10^-10.
And we get a K for the overall
reaction of 3.6x10^10,
which is an enormous number.
And so this would lie very,
very far to the right.
This is a much,
much stronger acid than NH four
plus.
If you know something,
if you have acid-base on both
sides of the equilibrium and you
know about the strengths,
you could predict where the
equilibrium of an overall
reaction is going to lie.
All right.
This is still on the handout
from Monday.
We mentioned that there are
five different types of
acid-base problems that you are
going to encounter in this unit.
And there are problems of salt
and water, which we are going to
see today break down to a weak
acid or a weak base in water
problem.
It is really not a different
type of problem at all.
There is weak acid in water,
weak base, strong acid,
strong base,
and there are buffer problems.
And when we do titrations it
will seem like that is a
different kind,
but it also breaks down into
these categories.
One trick that I have learned
from teaching this for a number
of years is to get people
starting to think about what
type of problem it is whenever
they see it and figuring out,
then, they know how to address
that problem.
Always be thinking about what
type of problem is this,
and so how do I go about
solving it.
We are going to look at the
first, number one here,
a weak acid in water problem.
And the weak acid that I picked
to look at is vitamin C.
In this particular problem we
are going to ask what the pH
would be if I take this vitamin
C tablet, a 50 mg tablet,
and put it into 100 milliliters
of water.
And usually when you try to
swallow vitamin tablets you try
not to dissolve them,
but if we did then we could
look at the pH.
I actually tried to do the
calculation and do the actual
experiment one year and
discovered that these vitamin C
tablets are coated really well.
You cannot get them to dissolve
very easily.
That is because you don't want
the bad taste in your mouth.
Nature's Bounty,
if you don't want this table to
dissolve in your mouth before
you swallow it,
I guarantee it won't.
You have to go to extreme
lengths to get this to dissolve
in your mouth.
We cannot actually measure the
pH of this because it is not
going to dissolve,
the coating is pretty good,
but we can do the calculations,
if the coating was less good,
what the pH of that would be.
All right.
The first thing we need to know
is molarity.
And so you can do this
calculation.
You know the number of
milligrams.
Convert it to grams.
Look up the molecular weight.
Calculate how many moles that
is.
And then that number of moles
in your 0.1 liters or 100
milligrams.
And you can get the molarity of
a vitamin C tablet in 100
milliliters of water.
Then you would need to write
the equation for a weak acid in
water problem.
And so here is our weak acid in
water.
It is forming hydronium ions
and a conjugate base.
Then you can set this up and
figure out what happens as
initially the change and then
what the concentration would be
at equilibrium.
In the beginning you just have
this molarity,
the 0.0284 molar solution.
And you don't have any of these
initially.
The change would be minus x and
then plus x, plus x.
At equilibrium,
we're 0.0284 minus x,
and, again, plus x.
Now to solve for x,
which is what we want to solve,
we want to find out pH.
And pH is the minus log of the
hydronium ion concentration.
We need to find x to be able to
find pH.
And to get x,
we can do that if we know the
Ka for the solution,
write out the expression,
hydronium ion,
conjugate base over acid,
we are leaving out the water
again, that would be equal to x
squared, 0.0284 minus x.
Now
we can try an assumption.
And this will be useful to you
on exams.
First you can try to say,
what if x was really small?
What if x was much,
much smaller than this 0.0284?
Then this term just collapses
into the number.
You can make that assumption
and try it and see if it works.
And I will tell you what the
rule will be to check that out.
If we try the assumption,
then we have just x squared
over this number.
That is easier to solve.
And we can solve for x.
Here x is 0.00151.
And I am
carrying an extra significant
figure.
Then we can go and check,
is this true that that is,
in fact, much smaller than
this?
And the rule that we will use
is 5%.
You can calculate whether the
number is 5%.
Take x over your initial number
times 100%.
In this case,
it was 5.3%,
which is more than 5%,
and so you should use the
quadratic equation to solve for
x.
Most of you normally use
calculators, which there is no
problem in doing quadratic.
But, of course,
the calculators we use on the
exams are not so amenable to
doing this.
I suggest on an exam,
you always try the assumption
that you can make it a simpler
problem to save yourself time.
The rule is 5%.
It has to be less than 5%.
I will just mention that the
book talks about this expression
and refers to percent ionized to
percent deprotonated.
This equation,
which is really x over the
number minus the initial
molarity minus x,
is how much you have gone to
that side of the equation,
how much you have deprotonated,
what the percent ionization is.
You will see those terms in the
problem set and in the book.
If you use the quadratic
equation then you get 0.00147.
And we are still carrying an
extra significant figure.
That is really two significant
figures.
The Ka just had two significant
figures that were given.
If we now solve,
this is x when x was the
hydronium ion concentration,
so pH is minus log of the
which would be 2.83.
And since this was really two
significant figures,
now you have two significant
figures after the decimal point.
That would be the correct
significant figure number for
this.
Remember this 5% rule to make
your life easier,
and also in all of these
problems you want to pay
attention to the significant
figures.
Again, the rules for logs in
significant figures are a little
complicated and require some
thought.
All right.
That is a weak acid in water
type problem.
And the weak base is going to
be very, very similar to that.
And so today we are going to be
going on and talking about weak
bases.
We are going to talk about salt
solutions.
And I will try to prove to you
that salt solution problems just
break down to weak acid problems
and weak base problems.
Yeah?
No, that is the same X.
It is just a question of this,
is it smaller than the number,
so back here,
it's not that it is an
incredibly small number.
It is just within the
significant figures smaller than
this number so that if you
subtracted it from that number
it would not really make any
difference.
This one?
This is the assumption that the
number x is going to be enough
smaller than 0.028 that if you
subtracted x from that number
you would still get that number.
Here you are getting plus x.
You are forming this amount of
hydronium ion,
this amount of the conjugate,
and that is the same amount
that is forming here that what
you are taking away from your
initial over here.
It is the same x.
You are not really saying that
this is an infinitesimally small
number.
You are just saying that it is
smaller than this to the degree
that it is not changing this
very much, so you don't have to
actually do that subtraction.
And so the rule we use for that
is 5%.
Again, there are these types of
problems.
Now we are going to look at a
weak base problem.
Let's look at a weak base
problem.
I need better chalk than that.
All right.
Weak base in water.
If we have NH three
plus water, it will go to the
conjugate of NH three,
which is NH four plus
and hydroxide ion.
If you are talking about a weak
base in water problem,
you are going to expect to see
hydronium ion on the other side.
And this is just a check that
you want to make sure you are
asking yourself as you are doing
these problems.
If you write the equation
wrong, you are going to be in a
lot of trouble.
Weak base should yield a basic
solution.
You should be getting hydroxide
ions out.
All right.
If we look at this problem,
we have an initial
concentration of 0.15 molar.
And we don't have any of this,
and we don't have any of that.
The change is going to be minus
x, plus x and plus x.
Then, at equilibrium,
we will have 0.15 minus x,
and we will have x,
and x.
Now it is a weak base in water,
so we are going to talk about a
Kb.
And so Kb is the base
ionization constant.
Kb is also going to be equal to
the products because it is an
equilibrium constant,
products over reactants.
And we are not including water
because it is the solvent.
This will be equal to x squared
over 0.15 minus x.
And
we can try this assumption again
that that might be equal to x
squared over 0.15.
The Kb is given.
And for a lot of the problems,
you will be able to look this
up in your book of 1.8x10^-5.
Again, it is a weak base.
It is less than one.
It has a Kb that is less than
one.
And so if we solve for x here,
we get x as 0.00164.
And now, we can check our
assumption that that is okay
using the 5% rule.
0.00164 over 0.15 times 100
gives you 1.1%.
You are checking the
assumption, and the assumption
is OK.
It is less than 5%,
so we can use that number.
Now we want to find out the pH
of this mixture at equilibrium.
And we have x.
x is equal to the hydroxide ion
concentration.
We can calculate,
first, pOH minus log of the
hydroxide ion concentration.
And so we have minus log of
0.00164, and we get 2.79.
This only had
two real significant figures.
We were carrying an extra one.
We only had 0.15.
We only had two significant
figures here.
This is going to get two after
the decimal point.
Since we have two here,
we get two sig fig's after
decimal.
Now we have pOH.
How do we get pH?
We can subtract from 14,
so the pH is going to equal
14.00 minus 2.79.
And it will be 11.21,
that will be the pH.
And I just want to remind
people, sometimes when you are
in a hurry on a test and you get
to this point and have this
number of 2.79 and you say,
oh, I am done.
But that is the pOH.
And, if you think about it for
a minute, a weak base in water,
a base in water should give
rise to a basic pH.
i.e., a pH greater than 7.
Below 7 is acidic.
Above 7 is basic.
You have to remember to convert
to pH.
The pH should be a basic
number.
Just keep it in mind,
as you are doing these
problems, think about what the
problem was.
Oh, it is a weak base in water,
does my answer make sense,
to kind of double-check that
you have gone the full
direction.
OK, so that is weak base.
Now we are going to talk about
salts in solution for a minute.
And salts in solution are going
to break down into weak acid and
weak base problems.
If you have a salt,
a salt can be formed by mixing
an acid in a base,
as shown up here,
but the pH of salt water is not
always going to be neutral.
If the salt contains,
for example,
the conjugate acid of a weak
base, then it contains a
conjugate acid,
so it will produce an acidic
solution.
Also, salts that contain some
small highly charged metals,
like iron three plus,
will also affect the pH.
This is something that you
should remember.
Group 1 and Group 2 metals or
metal cations with charges of
plus one, we have lithium,
calcium plus two,
silver plus one.
These are all going to be
neutral, but other things like
iron three plus will
not be.
Or, if you have a salt that
contains a conjugate base of a
weak acid, it is a conjugate
base, so it can produce a basic
solution.
If you remember on Monday,
we measured the pH of MIT tap
water and found that it was not
neutral.
It was pH 6 rather than 7,
so that would suggest that
there was some salt in that tap
water that was giving rise to a
non-neutral pH.
This is also review from last
time.
There is this relationship
between the conjugate acids and
bases.
This is not in your handout,
but just to remind you what we
were talking about,
if you have a strong acid,
its conjugate is ineffective as
a base.
If you have an acid that is
moderately weak to weak then it
will have a conjugate base that
is also moderately weak to very
weak.
And if you have a really strong
base then its conjugate will be
ineffective as an acid.
So, there is this relationship.
Let's take a look at some
examples of salts.
If we have NH four Cl.
If you are asked whether
putting some amount of this in
water will lead to an acidic
solution or a basic solution or
a neutral solution,
this is how you would approach
the problem.
First you are going to break
this compound through the middle
and consider two sides.
This salt will be composed of
NH four plus and Cl
minus.
Then, you are going to ask
whether this is a conjugate acid
of a weak base.
Is this a conjugate acid of a
weak base?
If it is a conjugate acid of a
weak base, then that will affect
the pH of the solution.
What is the conjugate of NH
four plus?
The conjugate of this is
ammonia.
If you take the weak base,
the conjugate,
the weak base is NH three.
And if you added a proton to
this you would get the conjugate
acid NH four plus.
This is a weak base,
so the answer to that question
was yes.
You could look it up in the
table.
Here is ammonia.
It has a Kb that is fairly
small so it is a weak base.
And we also had it on this
chart.
You had NH three over
here.
And so you could see that it
is, in fact, a weak base.
And we can look up the Kb for
that.
And so the Kb is 1.8x10^-5.
That is a weak base.
Because the conjugate is a weak
base, that means that the
conjugate acid is also a weak
acid.
And so this should be acidic in
solution.
That should be acid in
And let's just write that out
over here.
If we have NH four plus,
that has got to be a
weak acid because its conjugate
is a weak base.
And if we put the weak acid in
water, we should get the
conjugate base back plus
hydronium ion.
And the presence of the
hydronium ion is going to make
that acidic, and so this is a
weak base over here.
Its conjugate is a weak base.
And we can look up a Ka number
for it.
5.6x10^-10.
That is, in fact,
a weak acid.
And so here it is on this
table.
We can look it up.
And it is less than 1 and is
definitely a weak acid.
This part on this side of the
compound, we have something that
is going to produce an acidic
solution.
Now we have to ask,
well, what about this side over
here?
And so we would ask,
is this a conjugate base of a
weak acid?
Is Cl minus a
conjugate base of a weak acid?
What would be the conjugate
acid of Cl minus?
HCl.
So the conjugate is HCl.
Is that weak?
No.
This is a strong acid.
And that is one that you will
encounter a bunch,
so you will definitely have
that memorized by the time you
get through the problems.
It has a Ka over here of 10^-7.
If you put that in water,
if you had HCl in water,
it is a really strong acid,
Ka 10^7.
And so it would go pretty much
all the way to completion.
That means that this would be
ineffective as a base,
if you have a strong acid.
Again, there are these
relationships that we talked
about.
If something is a really strong
acid up here then its conjugate
is completely ineffective as a
base.
This then is going to be
neutral.
Because this is not going to
change the pH anymore,
it is ineffective as a base.
It is not going to make the
solution basic at all.
Whereas, on the other side,
NH four plus is a
conjugate acid of a weak base,
so it will produce an acid
solution.
The answer is that this salt in
water will be acidic.
If you were given an amount of
this compound,
if you said 0.15 molar,
for example,
what is the pH,
you could work that out by just
doing a weak acid type problem
and solving for x here and
calculating pH.
This particular salt in water
problem is just a weak acid in
water problem.
OK.
Let's look at another example.
Again, we are going to take
this compound and break it up.
And we will form Na plus
and CH3COO minus.
Then we ask is this a conjugate
acid of a weak base?
And what is the answer?
Where do you think it probably
came from?
Yeah.
It probably came from NaOH.
This one, the answer here is
no.
And we talked about rules that
all Group 1 and Group 2 are
neutral.
Group 1 ions are neutral.
Group 1 and Group 2 are
neutral, so this in solution
will be neutral.
All right.
Let's look at the other side
and ask, is this the conjugate
base of a weak acid?
And what would be the acid
here?
Yeah, acidic acid.
We have CH3COOH.
And we can look to see if that
is a weak acid.
And we can look it up here.
And so we have,
get the right line,
1.76x10^-5.
Is that a weak acid?
Yes.
If it is a conjugate base of a
weak acid then in solution it is
going to be basic.
And we can work that out.
If we wrote it out,
we have CH3COO minus
in water is going
to yield hydroxide ions and the
conjugate acid over here,
and the presence of this,
of the hydroxide ion will make
the solution basic,
so this is a weak base on this
side.
And so if you were asked,
given an amount,
you could solve the problem
using the Kb of the weak base,
solving for OH minus,
finding pOH,
and then pH.
Overall, this salt in solution
will give rise to a basic
solution.
You should have a pH greater
than 7, so this salt and water
would give rise to a basic
solution.
And this salt and water problem
breaks down into a weak base in
water problem.
Let's just do the generic --
-- type of problem.
In the general case,
if we have made-up compound XZ.
Made-up compound XZ will break
down into X plus and Z
minus.
And you are going to ask is
this a conjugate acid of weak
base, or you are asking,
basically, is this going to be
acidic?
If the answer is yes --
If you have a conjugate of a
weak base, which is a weak acid,
you will have an acidic
solution.
If the answer is no,
you will have a neutral,
at least in terms of the X.
On the other side,
for the Z minus,
you are asking the question,
is this a conjugate base of a
weak acid?
If it is a conjugate base of a
weak acid then it is going to be
basic.
It will be a weak base.
And so the answer is yes,
you are going to get a basic
solution.
If the answer is no here it
will be neutral.
And in these problems,
in the short answer type format
here, you are not going to be
given a case where one side will
be acidic and the other side
will be basic because then you
cannot give a short answer to
that problem.
You would have to figure out
which one is more acidic and
which one was more basic.
In these types of problems one
side will always be neutral,
or they could both be neutral,
you will see examples where
both of them are neutral,
but you are looking at each
side and asking a question about
it.
That is how you go about doing
these salt and water problems.
All right.
This leads us right into
buffers.
Buffers, this is another type
of problem that we will have.
Again, you are talking about
weak acids and weak bases here.
A buffer is any solution that
maintains pretty much a constant
pH despite the addition of a
small amount of acids and bases.
Buffering is all about constant
pH.
An acidic buffer is just a
buffer that is going to pH or
stay at sort of a constant pH in
the acid range,
so the acid side of neutral,
and it would consist of a weak
acid and its conjugate base
supplied as a salt.
A basic buffer will have a weak
base and its conjugate acid
supplied as a salt,
and it is going to buffer on
the basic side of neutral.
That makes a lot of sense.
All right.
Let's look at a buffer example.
In all buffers,
you are going to have an acid
mixed with its conjugate in the
form of a salt to get a dynamic
equilibrium.
And so if we have this,
we have the acid and its
conjugate added here.
And we ask what happens if you
add a strong acid to this
solution?
Again, what we want to have a
buffer do is maintain a constant
pH.
You need to have about the same
amount of this guy as this guy
for that to be true.
If you added strong acid and
you had some of this and some of
this, the acid is going to react
with a conjugate base and drive
it in this direction using up
the amount of strong acid that
was added.
The added acid,
hydronium ions are effectively
removed and the pH stays pretty
much constant.
Now what happens if you add a
strong base?
Well, a strong base is going to
react with the weak acid over
here.
And it will also be consumed.
And so the OH is removing a
proton, it is reacting with the
weak acid, and it will form more
conjugate base and it will also
form water.
Again, it is effectively
removed and the pH stays pretty
much constant.
A buffer should be a source in
a sink for added problems to the
reaction.
It is going to use up either
the acid or the base that is
added and keep the pH pretty
much constant.
Again, what is happening is
that the weak acid that you use,
and you can have anyone there,
is going to transfer protons to
this.
And that will cause the
reaction to happen and use up
the hydroxide ion.
A conjugate base that is added
as a form of a salt would then
be able to accept protons from
any acid that is used.
So you need both the weak acid
and the conjugate base added in
the form of salt.
One will react if you add extra
acid.
One will react if you add
excess base.
Why wouldn't a strong acid and
the conjugate base of that
strong acid make a good buffer?
Right.
Because the conjugate base
would be ineffective as a base.
And so the strong acid would go
to completion,
would drive to the right.
This is ineffective as a base,
so you are not going to push it
back the other way.
You are only going to have a
good buffering system with a
weak something and its conjugate
that is also a weak something.
A weak acid and its conjugate
weak base, a weak base and its
conjugate weak acid.
That will buffer because it
will go both directions.
Both conjugates have to work as
an acid or a base.
If you have a strong acid then
its conjugate is ineffective as
a base.
It won't work.
If you have a strong base then
its conjugate is ineffective as
an acid and it won't work.
All right.
Base buffering example,
the same stuff applies here.
If you add a strong acid,
it will react with the base.
The base will accept the
protons and make more of the NH
four.
And it will use up the strong
acid.
When a strong base is added,
it will react with the
conjugate acid and go the other
direction.
And so you will form more of
the conjugate base and water.
Again, the pH is staying the
same.
You are using up the strong
base that is added.
In a buffer action you have a
weak base accepting protons
supplied by the strong acid and
you have the conjugate acid of
the weak base transferring
protons to the hydroxide,
the strong base that is added
using that up as well.
Again, it is about going both
directions of the reaction.
That makes something a good
buffer.
A buffer mixture of a weak
conjugate acid and base
stabilize the pH of a solution
by providing a source or sink
for the protons.
Either they are providing a
source to neutralize the OH that
is minus or a sink for
the protons that are added in
the form of acid,
so the pH stays pretty much the
same.
You need something that can do
this dynamic equilibrium to be a
good buffer.
Let me just give you,
in the last couple minutes,
an example of why buffering is
important from a human health
perspective.
All right.
Your blood is buffered around a
neutral range,
and the buffering agents are
shown here.
Carbonic acid and bicarbonate
are effective as buffering
agents.
They can provide the source or
sink for added stress to the
system, for added acid or added
base, so you blood is buffered.
And this is really important.
If your blood pH changes --
Enzymes are designed to work at
particular pHs.
Molecules are not necessarily
stable at certain pHs.
Our body would not work well if
it was not appropriately
buffered.
Let me give you an example of a
genetic defect that overwhelms
the buffering capacity of the
blood and leads to a condition.
This is an enzyme that you have
in your body.
It is in your mitochondria.
And it requires vitamin B12.
This is what the enzyme is
involved in.
It is involved in breaking down
fatty acids to form energy.
Most people like this enzyme.
They are very happy with this
enzyme.
Most people want their fat
converted to energy,
and so this enzyme helps out
with that going on.
All right.
What happens if you have a
genetic defect or if you don't
have enough vitamin B12,
but in this case they are
talking about a genetic defect,
this step is blocked.
Your body is making a lot of
Methylmalonyl-CoA and it doesn't
know what to do with it.
It is a huge amount,
and so it actually gets
excreted from the body in the
form of an acid.
And so this leads to a
condition known as methylmalonic
aciduria.
There is so much of this made
that you are excreting like a
gram of this acid every day.
The blood is overwhelmed.
It cannot handle that much
acid.
Its buffering capacity is not
that good.
All right.
What causes this problem?
I will tell you that this now
is the amino acid sequence of
the enzyme.
Enzymes are made up of multiple
amino acids strung together in a
polypeptide chain.
And down here is the number
721, so this is a lot of amino
acids.
And at the time there were
these babies born with this
condition, and the doctors did
not know what to do to treat
them and a lot of the babies
died.
A number of them got together
and tried to sequence the gene.
Now, of course,
there is the Human Genome
Project so we know a lot of the
sequences of the genes.
But the doctors sequenced this
gene and sat down with the
parents and said,
OK, there is a mistake right
here, where that red arrow is.
It should be a glycine residue
but it is something else.
All right.
Imagine you are a parent.
You have a kid and the doctor
tells you there is a mistake
right here.
Well, that is fantastic.
What are you going to do about
it?
Well, at the time,
the doctors had no idea what to
do about it because they didn't
really know what was going on
here.
This answer partly came through
structure determination.
They found that vitamin B12
changes shape when it binds to a
protein.
Here is vitamin B12.
It has this group attached to
the cobalt when it is free.
When it is bound to the protein
it looks like this.
This long group is extended
into the core of the protein.
The protein needs a big hole to
put this group.
And so this is a model of what
the protein looks like and here
is a model of vitamin B12.
We discovered that it fits like
this.
It is fantastic.
There is a huge hole in the
protein into which you can put
the vitamin.
How did nature create a hole?
How did it make this space for
the vitamin to fit and then with
the vitamin bond it is active?
What it did was put the
smallest amino acids it could
find over here.
Now, what happens in this
mutant protein is that one of
those small amino acids was
converted into something larger
in the dark blue.
This was the protein that these
babies had.
And the doctors kept giving
them more B12,
more B12, more B12 and it
didn't do any good at all,
because no matter how much you
gave, it couldn't bind.
It was blocked.
The binding was blocked.
This suggested to doctors that
instead of giving them the full
vitamin B12, basically take a
pair of scissors and chop off
part of it and create something
that looked more like this and
then try to see if that would
then bind to the mutated
protein.
That is the kind of thing that
they were looking at,
trying to alleviate this
particular condition because the
buffering of the blood is pretty
good.
If could you restore some
activity, get rid of some of the
acid, you might be able to have
a more normal pH.
Okay.
Have a good weekend.